[Music]  virtually every industry  that has employees in our valley  is going to be participating in this job  fair there's never been another job fair  quite like it  was clark county commissioner jim gibson  discussing the huge job fair  this friday taking place at the  convention center from nine to two  more than a hundred employers local  hotels manufacturing government customer  service positions  walk-ins are welcome but  pre-registration through the nv career  center  website is suggested  it's not a minimum wage job these are 12  or more jobs many have traded or more  jobs  and as jim said there's over ten  thousand opportunities  so this this is a real opportunity  and once again we don't want you to miss  it it is happening this friday from nine  to two more than a hundred employers  find the link on our website at eight  newsnow dot com